help me welcome to the stage president
of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
everybody
hello Hall H now I could spend 90
minutes talking about what we've done or
I could spend some time talking about
what we're about to do phase four of the
MCU and we're going to take you through
all the projects were working on from
2020 to 2021 the Eternals something
entirely new entirely different for the
MCU a group of immortals who've been on
earth for thirty five thousand years
they've been there amongst the MCU we
haven't met them before this film is
full Jack Kirby and I want you guys to
say a big hello to our director director
of Eternals Chloe Zhou
do you guys have any interest in meeting
some of the Eternals alright ladies and
gentlemen as Icarus Richard Madden Pingo
Kumail Nanjiani as Macari Lauren
gridlock as fast Oh Brian Tyree Henry
I'm going to bring out the leader of the
Eternals playing a jack Salma Hayek
let me introduce playing sprite Lea
McHugh and his big bad Gilgamesh
Don Lee and finally unbelievably playing
FINA Angelina Jolie
[Applause]
everybody's big round of applause
[Applause]
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier coming
to Disney's new streaming platform
Disney Plus this Disney Plus let me tell
you something is giving Marvel Studios
an opportunity to tell so many more
stories that we haven't been able to
tell before most specifically what's
going on with the Falcon Winter Soldier
post endgame ladies and gentlemen
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan
[Applause]
you take it you take hold
thank you that's enough let me let me
get it back no we all right sorry yeah
be careful
Jiang Shi and the legend of the ten
rings the director of shang-chi destin
cretton hi everybody it is a huge honor
for me to introduce you to the
incredible scene lu lu
one division another mega event series
we're doing on Disney Plus how about you
meet one to Maximoff Lizzy Olson and the
vision Paul Bettany
[Applause]
Hey meet your new Monica Rambeau Tiana
Paris
[Applause]
Loki is coming to Disney Plus the
question I got asked more than any other
question after endgame was where did
Loki go what happened to Loki this
series will tell you what happened to
Loki right after that he goes through a
number of places I don't want to spoil
them but I will spoil the first place he
went he came to Hall H ladies and
gentlemen Tom Hiddleston
[Applause]
[Music]
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
say hi to the director Scott Derrickson
[Applause]
you know it takes me back dr. strange
what the fact that Benedict Cumberbatch
plays him yes absolutely ladies and
gentlemen Benedict Cumberbatch
[Applause]
hello I heard you had a little bit of
planes trains and automobiles situation
getting here to Hall H all during your
birthday not just at this because Hall
age is so important I feel bad but my
birthday yesterday and they very I think
you all know where I'm gonna go with
this yeah because it's not licensed we
won't be sued to you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you have a strong sorcerer it also
helps when you have a strong witch and
the Scarlet Witch is appearing in this
movie alongside er
let's bring Lizzy Olsen back out the
very very first animated series ever
from Marvel Studios we've been working
on these movies for 10 plus years
they're always ideas we have always
other things we want to try and with
this all of those set in stone MCU
scenes and experiences you've seen
before you will see different versions
of in this something incredibly exciting
about it is that a huge majority of the
actors from our movies are reprising
their roles in very different forms in
this animated series and you may have
heard an awesome voice narrate that
piece that awesome voice is the watcher
played in this series by the amazing
Jeffrey Wright
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Hawkeye himself
jeremy renner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
jeremy renner Kevin Feige The Wizard of
Oz a man behind the curtain makes it all
happen right Hawkeye the event series
coming to Disney Plus ladies and
gentlemen Taika Waititi give it up for
Chris Hemsworth and Chester Thompson
[Applause]
those of you know that storyline it's
incredible it's full of emotion and love
and thunder and it introduces for the
first time female Thor so for us there's
only one person who could play that role
only one and she's here and then should
you say to you now please welcome the
stage Natalie Portman
[Applause]
say hello to the director Kate Shortland
and meet the cast is Alexi David Harbor
as you Lena Bulova Florence Pugh playing
Mason ot feck Bentley
as Molina Academy award-winner Rachel
vice
[Applause]
and of course the Black Widow herself
Scarlett Johansson
I'm digging those hats well thank you
get this old thing that little thing I
don't suppose you might have brought
seven thousand extras
of course we did
here they come all right as soon as you
get one please make sure and put it on
because we are going to take a group
photo together should we bring back out
everybody solutely you should bring back
out everybody we have everybody all
right okay I think okay I think we have
everybody on stage so if you guys want
to turn around to face the photographer
are we good
already one two three everybody chair
[Applause]
but I want to leave you today with one
more thing that I don't think has been
rumoured about ladies and gentlemen
two-time Academy Award winner Maher
Sheila Ali
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not it it looks like it looks like
you brought your own hat rehearsal oh
you did what is that
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Hall H we'll see you next time
love you thank you thank you
you
[Music]